How is autoimmune disease diagnosed?
So a lot of people think that they might have an autoimmune disease.
They've been diagnosed with an autoimmune disease.
Most of the time it's the other way around.
They don't think that they have autoimmune disease
and they do have an autoimmune disease.
And it's never been diagnosed.
Not exactly the other way around.
But that's usually this real scenario that's taking place.
The truth is, is that just about everybody in a short period of time
are going to be dealing with an autoimmune disease by which you say that.
Because we live in such a toxic world that toxins are the number one thing
biotoxins as well.
Getting at our system, crossing damaged barriers,
gut barriers, lung barriers, skin barriers.
Toxins that our ancestors were never exposed to.
Toxins that people are ejecting into their arm,
we're letting somebody inject into their arm
in the guys that it's actually protecting them.
That's causing their body to create antibodies to self-tition.
So remember, your immune system does one thing.
And it's meant to do only one thing that is kill things.
So your immune system is only created to kill biotoxins,
a pathogen, an enemy, a virus, a bacteria, some fungus that's in your body.
But when we have this overabundance of toxins in our body
that is overwhelmed in our liver, detoxification pathways
and then being shunted out of the blood into the extracellular spaces
and or into the cells, cytoplasm.
Your immune system will attempt to kill it, can't kill it.
Over and over again, can end up firing a B cell reaction
and create antibodies against the neighboring tissue to the toxin.
So that is a major reason, one major reason why we have
autoimmune disorders and definition of autoimmune diseases
that you have antibodies to self-tissue.
And then you could go into my videos on autoimmune diseases
the different phases of autoimmune disease.
You could have a latent phase, you could have a reactive phase.
So go into that video to understand that.
Long answer for a short question.
An autoimmune disease is diagnosed based upon a showing,
a person showing positive tissue antibodies.
And then you go into the different phases of an autoimmune disease
and then when you're in that third phase, that very reactive autoimmune phase,
where you're really getting symptoms and tissue destruction.
That's when, so there's some gray area in the diagnosis.
So if I do a thyroid panel and I show TPO antibodies,
but I just do a thyroid panel as a screen, I don't have
any thyroid symptoms whatsoever.
So therefore, you're not going to see tissue destruction
of the thyroid, but if I have no thyroid symptoms whatsoever,
I might have elevated TPO antibodies.
So technically, I may have poshimoto's,
but the doctor may not give you a diagnosis, poshimoto's,
if you showed all signs of low or high thyroid issues,
graves at this time.
But so an autoimmune disease is diagnosed by a blood test showing positive tissue
antibodies. But then that's the technical diagnosis,
but then the clinical diagnosis is when those are
accompanied by symptoms and or worst case scenario symptoms and tissue
destruction. So that's how an autoimmune disease is
diagnosed.